ehi è da tanto tempo che volevo dirtelo
io ti amo ti penso sempre ti sogno la
notte
insomma spero che tu provi le stesse
cose per me te l'ho detto finalmente
ehi ma che ci fai qui io abito proprio
qua se vuoi una di queste sere ci
facciamo un aperitivo dai allora a presto
ciao ciao ciao come stai
e come sta tua sorella
non era tua sorella beh allora salutami anche lei
cosa gli scrivo cosa posso scrivergli che
lo colpisca ei frate come butta ci
vediamo oddio gliel'ho inviato veramente
oddio ma cosa ma sono impazzita ei frate come
butta ci vediamo ma da sottona proprio
o mio dio
si ma sei pazzo ma potevi avvisarmi
guarda mi cogli impreparata sono mezza
nuda vabbè vieni dentro dieci minuti e sono
pronta aspettami qui
si? si ehm dammi un secondo forse un pó di più
beh in realtà sarei a dieta ma visto che sei affamato
potrei prepararti un arrosto con patate e una parmigiana
dammi dieci minuti ed è tutto pronto non
te l'avevo detto che ho lavorato anche
come chef in un ristorante stellato
ah ah vuoi mangiare
sì io non sono bravissima a cucinare
però vedo se ho qualcosa da offrirti
andiamo andiamo sotto c'è un posto molto
buono se vuoi fa gli hamburger
ciao katia allora ho un appuntamento super
importante per cui volevo prenotare una
ceretta completa piega manicure pedicure e un massaggio rilassante
ok con calma finalmente esco con crush
da dove possiamo iniziare
oddio io non esco sono troppo brutta come
faccio a farmi i capelli non ho neanche il rasoio
oddio puzzo da fare schifo devo farmi
la doccia 20 minuti no non ce la farò mai
vuoi che ti racconti qualcosa di me oddio non saprei da dove iniziare sono
diplomata col massimo dei voti ho
preso tre lauree una di queste ad oxford
ho vissuto in america ho fatto
volontariato per un anno in africa e ho
ricevuto un oscar qualche anno fa
vuoi sapere qualcosa di me mi piace fare
shopping ascoltare la musica e poi sabato sono andata al matrimonio di mia cugina ed è stato
divertentissimo perché mi sono ubriacata
e ho vomitato addosso a mia nonna
e niente ma cosa fai una foto aspetta che mi metto in posa ma quante ne fai ma sei pazzo
cosa stai facendo no no una foto a me ma sei pazzo leva questo telefono sono orrenda perfavore
no veramente no dai veramente no dai
non ma é andata
troppo bene te lo giuro
lui poi super carino cioè proprio c'era intesa
hai capito quello che intendo
no veramente adesso boh vediamo magari mi scrive magari no aspetta un attimo
no vabbè non ci credo cioè telepatia mi ha appena scritto un messaggio mi ha
scritto non vedo l'ora di rivederti
sto male beh è fatta
niente niente silenzio stampa
non mi ha neanche scritto un ciao un like
eppure mi sembrava che il nostro
appuntamento fosse andato bene ma forse solo per me eccoci arrivati alla fine
del video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando
mettete un bel like lasciate un commento
qui sotto facendomi sapere in quali di
queste situazioni vi siete ritrovati di
piú vi ricordo inoltre di seguirmi su
tutti gli altri social in particolare
instagram tiktok e facebook vi mando
un bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo
video comodo
ciao